[Music]
and it is unacceptable totally
unacceptable the american people saw a
plain view
and i hope it's sensitized into what we
have to do
and that was president-elect joe biden
just a few moments ago condemning
yesterday's attack on capitol hill
calling the violent group that descended
on the u.s capital domestic terrorists
and blaming the violence on president
trump the president-elect also formerly
introduced his attorney general nominee
judge merrick garland among other picks
for his administration
we thank you for joining us for the news
here at noon everyone i'm alex backus
and more security measures are now in
place today in washington
one day after supporters of president
trump violently stormed
the building four people died yesterday
including one woman who was shot by
capitol police
we begin our coverage with deborah
alferon she has the latest for us from
capitol hill
a day after the assault at the u.s
capitol the army says a seven foot
non-scalable fence is being constructed
and additional national guard members
will arrive by this weekend
the security measures will be in place
for no less than the next 30 days
the fbi and local police are asking for
help finding those behind the violence
we have collected numerous images of
persons of interest
that we are asking the community to help
us identify
rioters stormed the building wednesday
some pro-trump protesters breached the
senate chamber
one sat at a desk inside speaker nancy
pelosi's office
the government did this to us we were
normal good law abiding citizens
and you guys did this to us police fired
at a woman who tried to climb through a
window
she later died the mayor of d.c wants
answers
we have some work to do to find out what
happened to make sure it doesn't happen
again
today it's quiet here at the capitol 150
additional national guard members are
maintaining a perimeter
around the complex there will be 6 200
guardsmen
in total by the weekend here congress
was in the process of confirming
president-elect joe biden's electoral
college win
at the time of the riot lawmakers took
cover
anywhere they could starts being fired
new york congressman tom swazi captured
the chaos on his cell phone
i started to leave the chamber and
started to hear pop
pop former attorney general william barr
an ally of president trump
issued a stunning rebuke saying
orchestrating a mob to pressure congress
is inexcusable
the president's conduct yesterday was a
betrayal of his office and supporters
in a statement president trump said
there will be an orderly transition on
january 20th
deborah alfarone cbs news capitol hill
three others died of medical emergencies
on the capitol grounds
more than 50 people have been arrested
so far